you talked about the rake can you
describe the rake
yeah i mean i was a rake uh i'm what you
call a reformed rate so i can speak from
experience on that
and basically my years of being rape
were in my twenties and pretty much
early 30s and then it was then i stopped
but the rake
is a man
who has an intense interest in women
he understands them deeply he's obsessed
with women and perhaps it comes from
something relationship going with his
mother you know we can analyze that as
well but he has this obsessive interest
in them he understands their spirit he
finds it very exciting to be around them
but one woman can never satisfy him
the only way he can get satisfaction is
by constantly having new women in his
life that's how he that's how he
satisfies this hunger because the moment
that a woman becomes familiar
it kind of loses the edge that he wants
he's kind of like a hunter he loves the
process of hunting the woman of of
seducing her of getting her to fall for
him
and in those first few weeks he showers
her with attention that's his power he
love bombs them he's so
he's so excited about their world he
gives them gifts that show he's thinking
about them he takes them to exciting
places it's
irresistible right and um but the thing
is it can't last because he has to
continually spread spread the well he
has to continually find new people to
conquer
and i i i in the book i kind of
um profile some of the greatest rakes
who ever lived
and one of them
is the is the great classic hollywood
actor errol flynn
um errol flynn was this devilishly
handsome man that didn't hurt but he was
also
in the end people claimed that he had
seduced or slept with about 3 000 women
and um and he died when he was 51 52
from alcoholism and so i went when i
wrote the book i kind of did the math on
that
and the math was rather insane it was
like at some point he had to be seducing
a new woman every other day something
like that
and
i was trying to figure out what was his
secret
what made him so insanely seductive to
women of all types actresses waitresses
you name it
of course being errol flynn and having
his reputation helped but he also had a
devilish edge that kind of scared a lot
of women
but i read in one book that just being
around he was so comfortable with
himself
he was so
non-defensive he was like an animal that
was completely comfortable in his body
and it was it made the woman completely
relaxed this one woman said
i felt like i had drunk a couple of
martinis and i hadn't just by being
around him
you know and so the rake has this kind
of undefensive quality he's like this
natural animal that exudes this energy
kind of like how the siren is
so that's sort of what a rake is
that was awesome
okay
cool okay so i was going to ask what the
equivalent of that was for a woman but
you're saying the siren kind of
yes um yeah definitely the siren i mean
you can't really have a male siren and
you really can't have a female rate
i mean um
i do profile in the in in that section
probably the greatest lesbian seductress
who ever lived natalie barney who was
kind of a poet and writer in the early
20th century
and she was the closest equivalent i
could come to a female rape
because um she was seducing women left
right and center and she had a little
bit of that presence but normally it's
something that's pretty specific to men
and women
okay
that description was amazing can i get
you to do one more
i guess
seductive type
you want me to list what the other ones
are yeah yeah
that was too cool we need to do more
oh well that was the the dandy i already
mentioned the natural which is the one
who's kind of like a child
then there's the coquette
blows hot and cold
very very powerful seductress
um there's the charmer who's very good
at sort of social seductions
there's the star
the person who kind of exudes kind of
like a like a film star presence that
makes everyone project their fantasies
onto him or her and there's the
charismatic somebody who just has that
natural charisma i can't think if i'm
leaving somebody oh the ideal lover
that those those the other seven types
so you choose whichever one you want
okay
well you said there was one where you
project your ideal lover on them
well
the star
is is sort of this person i use as the
example
the woman is marlena dietrich and the
man
who is john f kennedy excuse me
president john f kennedy and what it is
is they've learned the hollywood
technique and for marlena dietrich it
was clearly you know a film thing that
she learned
was you have a kind of blankness to you
you're not too obvious in what you say
in what you do you're not overtly this
way or that way you have a kind of an
emptiness to your face to your blankness
to how you move
and you allow people you don't talk too
much and you allow people to project
onto you their fantasies they see into
you what they want to see into you
whereas if you kind of
say who you are and you're pu too direct
they have they have a mysterious air
about them
and john f kennedy
he was obsessed with hollywood something
people don't understand know very well
he was obsessed with hollywood he was
obsessed with film stars and his
favorites film star from the classic age
of hollywood was montgomery cliff
very handsome young man from the late
40s early 50s and he modeled his whole
persona after montgomery clift that kind
of silent machismo that he exuded that
kind of certain look in his eye that
montgomery clift had
and
it was immensely powerful as we saw in
the election in 1960 where so many
people saw into him what they wanted to
see you know and he disguised the
reality he disguised the reality that he
was actually
a man in his 40s who was physically and
almost crippled he had all of these
illnesses he could his back was
incredible pain but he was able to
disguise all of it and project this
other image so these are the two people
that i chose to to kind of illustrate
that
wow
and then you're like yeah i'm sorry go
ahead no no you go ahead
well you're kind of like a blank screen
onto which people can see what they want
to see and there's a way to do that i
kind of describe in that chapter how you
can do that